September the 19th will see the first
funeral for a British monarch in decades
here is what you need to know
State funeral is held for people of
national significance usually monarchs
they include pageantry haunt and
ceremony usually with religious and
Military aspects
the last person to have a state funeral
was Winston Churchill in 1965. other
notable people include the Queen's
father King George VI Admiral Nelson and
Sir Isaac Newton
Prince Philip the Queen Mother and Diana
Princess of Wales had large televised
ceremonies but despite having a lot of
similarities they were not State
funerals
I don't think our City's ever seen
the sort of presence we're going to see
over the next few days this is a
military operation like any other we
plan it we rehearse it and then we
execute it and that I think helps with
the pressure the funeral will take place
on Monday the 19th of September here at
Westminster Abbey heads of state Prime
Ministers and presidents European Royals
and key figures from public life will
all be invited to gather in the Abbey
which can hold 2 000 people a bank
holiday has been declared on the day of
the funeral so schools will be closed
and many businesses and shops but a day
off isn't a right on a bank holiday
that's down to individual employers
after the funeral the Queen's coffin
will be taken to Saint George's Chapel
at Windsor Castle for a committal
service the queen will then be buried
alongside Prince Philip in the King
George VI Memorial Chapel
if you haven't got an invitation to the
funeral you can still watch some of it
on the morning of the funeral the
Queen's coffin will be taken from the
Palace of Westminster where it's lying
in state to Westminster Abbey in a
ceremonial procession Chief mourners now
move out to follow Diana Princess of
Wales members of the royal family are
going to walk behind the coffin like
they did for Prince Philip and Princess
Diana
the public can go and watch that part
but big Crowds Are expected so expect
some very long cues and of course if you
want you can still watch it all on
television